so some identities are as philosophers
would say determinants that were
determinable so some are like race in
principle you know the racial system is
laid out so that you have to be of
either of mixed race or of one of the
races and you can't be as it were black
and an Asian at the same time you can be
mixed race but you can't be
straightforwardly Asian and straight
fluently black at the same time so in
that sense that mutual exclusivity is
built into the structure of some kinds
of identity but there's nothing in
general about identities that excludes
the overlap of different forms of
identity of gender and race and sexual
orientation and religion and nationality
in class or in a single person and
indeed most people have all of these
things why what's a sensible thought
about how to deal with them well first
of all and this relates to what the
proper answer to the question and what's
your identity is usually in a context
it's pretty clear which aspects of your
identity other ones that are relevant if
I'm at a meeting of the American
Philosophical Association my my identity
is a philosopher is kind of important
but if I go to a meeting church group it
probably isn't and so I know I know
without thinking about it often what the
relevance is of different dimensions of
my identity so when people are get into
trouble with us it's because they think
that one dimension of identity makes a
demand on them that's inconsistent with
the demand made by some other dimension
of their identity
I think there are sort of two helpful
guiding thoughts one is morality is
helpful here that's to say there are
general obligations we have to other
people independent of their identities
and our identities we better make sure
that we discharge those first of all so
if you find yourself being pulled in
two-dimensional directions by your
identities if you find yourself being
pulled in the one direction say as a
Serb and in the other direction as a
Christian it might be helpful to
remember that you're a human being and
that you have obligations to other
people that are not connected with
whether you're being you're a Serb or a
Christian so that's one thing morality
helps morality which which defines what
we owe to everybody irrespective of
their identities the second thing is
that sometimes we do have to make
choices that's part of what it is to
make a human life its - it's the way in
the balance am I going to go here with
my religious identity or am I going to
go here with my racial identity in this
particular context or am I going to try
and find some way here the two
unthought-of to bring them together
without that strong tension and people
are doing this all the time it could
sound very difficult in theory but I you
know my model for this really was my
father my father was in Asante and the
patriot of Asante a Ghanaian and a
patriot of Ghana he wrote an
autobiography called the autobiography
of an African Patriot because he was a
pen Africanist he was a devout Methodist
and very active in his church and cared
about his church and he was a citizen of
the world he was ambassador to the UN
for a while and he will he worked very
much an international affairs he cared
about relations among nations now you
might think how can you be a loyal
Asante and a loyal gummin after all
Asante is a kingdom in the middle of the
Republic of Ghana well the answer is you
know look at my father's life as it were
and look at lots of lives people do this
sort of thing all the time you can be a
loyal citizen of Texas and a loyal
American occasionally they'll pull you
in different directions and then
you have a choice to make but much of
the time you know being Texas Texan
there's going to be what matters for
some purpose isn't being American is
what matters for others and when they do
come into conflict you have many things
to appeal to to help you resolve the
conflict including I think your own
sense of the relative weight in your own
life which is up to you of your state
identity as opposed to your national
identity so you can't tell people you
can't these are things that have people
have to figure out for themselves
because there is no morally correct
answer no ethically pre-given answer to
the question what's more important Texan
or American what's more important you
know Christian or philosopher these
things are not you have to figure it out
for yourself I think all you can say to
people in trying to be helpful is that
you're often going to have people who
share one of these identities with you
make demands of you on that basis that
you're entitled to resist in the name of
your more of morality in the name of a
human human identity but also in the
name of other identities that you have
and which you don't share with them
everybody if you just I worked out the
other day that you only need to have 32
properties to consider only 32
properties to elect to have a set of
bundles of properties such that
everybody in the world can have a
distinct and unique bundle of bundle of
properties because two to the 32 is
bigger than six billion and they're only
six billion of us well so even in the
smallest village right there are both
men and women so all the other
identities are inflect are potentially
inflected by gender and among the women
some have more resources than others
some are married and some are unmarried
some have children some don't have
children
all of these affect how their lives look
to them and how they're going to make
the balance of these things in their
lives and the sort of the key thought of
the liberal tradition and goes back to
count goes back to Humboldt goes back to
the
slight mill in the 19th century the key
thought is each human being has to face
the challenge of making this decision
for herself you can take advice from
other people you should take advice from
other people other people can tell you
useful things but it's your
responsibility in the end to make a
decision and you shouldn't defer that
responsibility to anyone else